hi this is Amitabh Bachan I'm from India
I live in Mumbai I'm an actor and I've
been an actor for the last 14 years I've
done about approximately 150 kms and I'm
very honored to be here in Davos I've
been invited here because there was
Economic Forum his has very kindly
decided to honor me with their crystal
award an achievement in my in my
contribution to arts in films I really
don't know how credible that is as far
as I'm concerned because I I just look
upon myself as another actor
if I have been able to contribute in
some manner to the community of
entertainment in my country then I feel
very honored that to be here in Davos
and very hungry accept this this award
that they're giving me I've just been
here a few hours and therefore it's very
difficult for me to make out what Davos
is all about one reads about it one has
heard about it and has had the
opportunity very very briefly to move
around and I find a great amount of
energy and an interest among people from
different walks of life and businessman
from entertainment from politics talking
meeting discussing issues and I think
this is a wonderful wonderful occasion
for the entire world on must to converge
in one city in one Center and be able to
air and and give their opinion on views
that affect all of us whether a we live
in India or whether we live in the
United States of America over there we
live in Switzerland we all have our
point of views and this is an extremely
important forum for all of us to enhance
express ourselves I know that we have
opportunities individually to do
something like this but I think that
once all of us get together and
and have a forum a common form where we
can virtually talk to each other across
the table this lends a lot more
credibility it also becomes a lot more
important because what is talked off and
what is discussed here goes out to the
rest universe I hope that this is
conference in this forum this year does
exactly that
I hope the valuable topics are discussed
and I hope that those that listen in are
able to gather something imbibe
something from this and make it a
success if there is something that needs
to be talked about entertainment I'm
here and if you have any questions